hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Freddy's 3
this might be the most hype game in the
history of gaming and it might totally
be worth it because just compared to the
last two games going into it I'm
actually a little bit nervous just
because of the unknown factor there's
always been an unknown factor whenever I
launched into these games and that
twitchy bunny right there isn't helping
very much so I'm gonna get into this and
I'm gonna play it fast bears fright the
horror attraction local amusement parks
getting ready to scare your socks off
with a new attraction based on the
unsolved mysteries of Freddy fazbear's
pizza
featuring cool relics from decade's old
peace arena now together okay I don't
know
what it's already it's already 4:00 a.m.
I only go to 6:00 a.m. right there's so
much information in that spiel that I
don't even know how to process it holy
crap there's so much different than what
it was before this two layers to the map
how am I supposed to keep track of all
this and apparently when I go into these
cameras I'm supposed to sound some noise
whenever I eat I need to go someplace
for some reason or something because
here's here's what I was thinking this
was I was thinking the entire time that
I was seeing all the previews for the
game the only thing that I noticed the
entire time was that there was only one
animatronic and and and the reason
behind that is and the reason I think
that is is because it's like a
Frankenstein's monster combination of
all the different animatronics so it
like took the base of Bonnie and like
the yellow of chica it's not actually
golden Bonnie but maybe it is a little
bit golden body but I think it's just
the yellow of chica and then the
intimidation of Freddy itself is
all narrowed in one and to be honest I'm
totally lost as to what I'm supposed to
do there's so much to look at what am I
supposed to do what do you want from me
why are you blinking and why can I look
at yeah I did oh god I got beat the
first night that's a spectacular
spectacle what the hell am I supposed to
do with my life now I know I'm supposed
to roll right in tonight - OH
oh hi
okay back to this again is that a rat
this is one under there uh oh hi hello
what's that purple Freddy is that the
purple guy I don't wanna fall um why am
i following him is that thunder is this
place decrepid there's so many boarded
up place it's those are rat error error
error okay all right then
guess I can't go that way for summer
what the hell yeah oh good good second
night great why is this a thing
three approach to making sure the
animatronics say where the children are
for maximum entertainment / crowd to
change the animatronics instead mode
endeared an inherent Burma in the
hand-crank provided by the manufacturer
turning the crank will be coil and the
animatronic around what's happening okay
it's over then so how's the ventilation
system that I needed monitor but what
the hell did I need to do that oh god
what's going on
everything you'll horribly wrong boo to
that stop that
game over okay that's what I expected to
happen
what I didn't expect to happen was
everything else happened
don't worry buddy I don't even have a
name for you yet I don't think it's in
my right to name you bunny bastard [ __ ]
balls
that's your name bunny bastard [ __ ]
balls okay so anyway what I'm supposed
to do I'm trying to piece together what
I'm supposed to do because this game is
totally different than the other games
which is entirely what the developer was
trying to do and I'm pretty sure I saw
Balloon Boy there cuz who's that was the
preview picture the last preview picture
that was put out in sky games oh god I
forgot there's no call right now I'm
supposed to be oh god that's nothing
okay ventilation air already why is
there a ventilation error what does that
even mean it means I'm gonna hallucinate
stuff and the things that come after me
are not gonna be real so I'm assuming
that's what happened when oh why is that
a problem what's going on now why and
why did you have to find a real
electronic animatronic man animatronic I
don't know what I'm saying I just have
to find one what the hell did I see is
that Balloon Boy
why is Balloon Boy gotta be back there's
a balloon girl I don't even think I want
to know this is gonna be is gonna be a
long game it's gonna be long I can't
even imagine what the 20/20 mode on this
one so goddamn it I'm hyper pedaling I
apologize I'm very stressed at the
moment I can't flip between them quickly
because I know that Scott put that in so
oh what's that mangle that was mangle
why did it put that down I didn't put
that down
hey wait hanging out with foxy your best
bros over there you lovers or something
I don't think I want to know the answer
why I saw that
by that pair I speaking over the pizza
what the [ __ ] am i dead
am I gonna die well uh audio error audio
error I need audio why do I need oh I
need to play audio in different laces
that's right okay so I gotta play audio
because he's nearby now he's like right
outside my goddamn door if that was
Bonnie that better have been Bonnie or
golden Bonnie for Goldy Bonnie goalie
goalie locks Goldilocks
there yeah Balloon Boy distract him whoa
I see you I see you there I see you
you're in the right corner he's right
the cordon right there he's right there
I came by to hear the noise there is
only one god I'm not holding it together
very well the night is night two is
going way slower the night one ever was
night one was breeze cuz that guy was
talking to me the whole time so high
okay so do i can like repeatedly do this
somewhere in there I might just not
seeing him it's like a pervert game
hide-and-seek my assistance dude doing
great apparently somehow the licen
somehow the ventilation went out and I
start hallucinating without even know
you
okay I gotta immediately play noise hey
another place so he doesn't come get me
or something
hello cloudy right here right there hey
what are you doing
friendly hello hi hey how's it goin bro
I'm gonna play
this is gonna take a while I have no
goddamn idea what I'm doing I have no
idea whatsoever no idea oh it was right
there in the doorway song he's right by
the decrepit Freddy why does he need to
be there I like seriously not handling
this very well I thought it would be
able handle I am like an expert at the
other five nights at Freddy's games just
because I play them for hours and hours
and hours trying to be 20 mode but god
damn this one but I don't even know
where to start with this and the one
thing that's great about it is that each
series expands on the previous without
intermingling and without overlapping
too much it carries on the same theme
while still being terrified why does why
does chica have little vampire teeth
that is adorable
that is freaking adorable and that
goddamn fan and this box if [ __ ] here
it's all the toy creatures that didn't
make it from the last one and I know I
saw him angle
I saw him angle a ventilation air okay
alright how am I supposed to know about
the ventilation error I guess I got a
check I can see Levin and that does a
thing which is good I guess but there's
also a vent that leads like right next
to me hi thanks Balloon Boy for the
assist I'm gonna high-five you later
before I punch you in the face and then
I'm gonna punch you in the face some
more just cuz I don't like you I'm gonna
hug ya okay so that's the exit so that's
where I am never did something change
why does it do that
why does it do that I don't like it when
to do that why does it always pulse like
that is he actually there is he actually
there and I don't see him yelling into
my microphone right now call him to me
okay to a goddamn wise you go so slow
see this is what happens when I panic I
just start spouting nonsense and it
doesn't make any sense
or help makes its way I'm trying to like
rationalize through what the hell is
going on in me and to be perfectly
honest I have no goddamn idea all right
I think seems to be fine I think I think
it's the noise that I'm making alright
goddamn balloon boy oh just about just
turn it back on okay so that's a problem
because it's noises and lights blaring
in my office yeah please don't have time
to wait in the ventilation I need to
breathe now okay play audio over there
maybe it's cuz I'm using balloons boys
voice too much hey that's it maybe
that's the thing that can happen I don't
know it's all fear at this point it's
just a theory a game theory audio air
audio air audio air are you air I'll
hate it if my camera system goes out
because I don't think I'll be able to
handle that camera system to go out you
got to put it back up come on please
I'll give you some lovin I'll give you
some sweet camera lovin okay maybe not
that sounds totally wrong in this aspect
where I'm just talking myself in the
room in the camera why like am I
supposed to calculate like where I find
him in there and what avenues that he
could go through in the vents is that
like something that I'm supposed to
eventually consider because that's a
stance right now I don't know I don't
have the whole place memorized yet I
wouldn't have the capability I'd say yo
hey did you come say hi Bloomberg huh
Goldilocks you got me don't flicker in
there now I'll play audio in your face
hi how's it going I'm communicating
thousand mistake wasn't fence fence
I heard vets I'm sealing them all
zoomable oh god oh god I can only see it
one other time oh god oh that's all the
one I won't see [ __ ] okay okay
five am i've always done how do I get
out of here how do I do this
am I almost done okay okay okay okay I
shouldn't feel this accomplished but I
do man I'm sweating okay okay Who am I
oh and Bonnie now oh good I'm Bonnie oh
great
where am I supposed to go now why is the
floor glowing purple has got to be
raining yeah that's what I think
happened in this game oh hey that's the
spirit first room can I remember like
this is the layout of the original game
I'm pretty sure follow me I don't want
to follow you purple why away you got a
few Purple's ready but we're Freddy so
bad there's probably other secrets that
I could find in this place what is the
same way I'm not gonna follow you I
don't feel like following I don't want
to follow I'm only this way I'm only
this way
oh I can't I can't deviate from my bath
oh there we go okay I think this is the
way oh it's the security room oh okay
alrighty then maybe I was supposed to
fall him fall okay I am supposed to
follow him I just wanted to explore a
bit more to see if there was more to
this and I'm willing about that there
are because one thing that Scott does is
he puts so many Easter eggs in these
damn games just so many oh wait a minute
oh if I'm remembering the layout
correctly what is any lead wait where
did he go okay that's what he's trying
to get me to follow him again
isn't that like the way to the exit look
am I mistaken about that oh that seems
to be the remains of a Freddy it's a
Frankenstein thought error oh god oh god
oh
jeez I didn't even know I could get to
the third night okay so I'm gonna nope
nope nope hang on okay you can actually
see the sweat dripping from my forehead
this is an awesome awesome experience
because it's totally different from what
I was getting through before and one of
the great things is that I was able to
get through the first two nights the
problem with the second game it was so
unbelievably hard like right now I don't
know what I'm doing but I was still able
to get through it now I know that later
in the nights it's going to get even
worse and you're gonna need like analyze
everything that's going on but there's a
lot of substance here now I don't know
when the game officially releases this
is just demo but obviously there's a
third night available so I'm gonna try
to play that now in another episode hey
it is what it is more five nights at
Freddy's I hope you guys enjoyed this
video thank you guys so much for
watching check out the whole five nights
at Freddy's playlist and all the other
animations that were made of it in the
description below are the annotations
over there thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
okay